[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie we
have our first look preview at James
Gunn's
Suicide Squad they're calling it the
Suicide Squad instead of calling it
Suicide Squad - but it effectively is a
sequel to the first movie I'll explain
what the timeline and the continuity is
and how they're going to handle it and
why all these characters look so crazy
we're doing a movie ticket giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be subscriber
and leave your favorite Suicide Squad
character on the video so just to
clarify what's going on with this movie
this is set after the events of the
first Suicide Squad movie and instead of
doing a full blown reboot of the first
Suicide Squad movie they're keeping the
Suicide Squad as the title it just
writing into the story why it is there's
so many different versions of the
Suicide Squad in a way that's funny but
also explains the concept of the team
Amanda Waller taking criminals that
nobody cares about using them for the
worst of the worst jobs that none of the
heroes want to do because they might die
and the Suicide Squad members are all
expendable
so once I explain some of these
ridiculous characters that they have and
why they seem so silly it'll make more
sense because part of the idea is is
that you kill off members of the Suicide
Squad just to show how expendable they
are at the beginning of each of the
movies
hold your fire sorry that's what I do
but several characters from the first
film are coming back for the second film
just letting you know where it fits in
the timeline in that they're not
completely wiping the first Suicide
Squad from history
I'll explain these characters then I'll
explain the story just a little bit the
setup is actually pretty hilarious but
in a good way first there's mei-ling as
female Mangal Mangal with an A not [ __ ]
she's the daughter of mongaul in the
comics she's only been used a couple
times she showed up during our worlds at
war she kind of worked with the heroes
but she's mostly known as a villain
Nathan Fillion is playing a Booster Gold
villain called blackguard he's a
character from the future I don't know
if they're gonna make him from the
future in the movie but he joins the
criminal gang the 1000 they give him
this special suit of armor that gives
him his abilities if you've been a fan
of Nathan Fillion for a long time you
probably get the meta joke in casting
him is a Booster Gold villain one they
need a bunch of ridiculous villains for
an early version of the team before the
real team surfaces but for the longest
time people have been asking Nathan
Fillion if he was ever going to play
Booster Gold in a DC movie going back
years people fan casting him as Green
Lantern so this is just sort of James
Gunn's joke in casting him is a really
ridiculous minor character riff on those
other big theories that fans have had
for a long time
[Music]
one of you saw Pete Davidson you're like
why is Pete Davison in the Suicide Squad
this seems crazy he was a self-styled
vigilante that tried to help people
initially but was terrible at it so he
turned to a life of crime hacking
started working for the Russian mafia he
became a birds-of-prey villain and then
eventually joined the Suicide Squad
after he was captured but he has
genius-level intellect he's an expert at
hand-to-hand combat he's really good
with computers I know you've all saw
this crazy yellow costume and you're
like who the hell is this this is
actually Flula Borg he's a former
YouTube comedian that's now been
starring in movies and television shows
he's actually made it pretty big but
because he's mostly known for doing
ridiculous comedy when people heard that
he was cast in Suicide Squad they're
like wait a minute what is Flula gonna
be doing in this movie he's playing a
character named javelin who's a former
Olympic athlete who turned to a life of
crime he became a Green Lantern villain
for a little while he doesn't really
have any special powers to speak of he's
just really good at hand-to-hand combat
athletics throwing his javelin to people
so he is a pretty ridiculous character
which will make more sense in a second
when I explained it all I know you're
all wondering who Sean Gunn is going to
be playing because clearly it's going to
be a motion-capture character he's
actually playing a character wait for it
called weasel during all the Marvel
movies he actually doubles as the
stand-in for rocket on screen when
Bradley Cooper isn't around because they
need someone to actually be that
character and run around on all fours
when they're walking around together in
the comics he's capable of transforming
into a weasel which is weasel like claw
animal type powers nothing really crazy
he was part of the Black Lantern Corps
for a little while because they killed
him off and then brought him back during
blackest night the only real reason they
recruited him into the Suicide Squad in
the comics is just because he was so
bloodthirsty and they felt like he would
be good asset during a mission then you
all recognize Jai Courtney coming back
as Captain Boomerang with a slightly
more tuned down version of his costume
not quite as dirty as the version we saw
in the last Suicide Squad movie just
confirming that this is continuing after
the events of the last film doll and I'm
walking out in frame
we're gonna start having some real fun
why don't we have some fun the other
characters that aren't pictured here but
that they've confirmed are John Cena
who's playing a character called
peacemaker
I'll explain him in a second David -
million from the ant-man movies is
playing polkadot man we don't know who
Taika Waititi is playing maybe another
big motion capture character but king
shark is being played by Steve Agee
at least that's what's being reported
they just did a big king shark versus
Grodd storyline last year on the flash
it was great
Danijela Melchior is playing a character
called ratcatcher peter capaldi is still
a mystery character it would be awesome
if he's playing mr. freeze but it'll
probably wind up being an obscure
character just because that seems like
what James Gunn is going for with this
new film picking the most ridiculous
most obscure characters possible with a
few exceptions Idris Elba obviously not
in this picture but he's supposed to be
playing vigilante he's the replacement
for Will Smith's Deadshot character
originally the idea was is they would
just recast Deadshot because either Will
Smith didn't want to come back or there
was a scheduling conflict then because
the producers didn't want to slap Will
Smith in the face by recasting him they
just picked a different character for
Idris Elba to play if you haven't
watched any of arrow they actually
featured the vigilante character on that
TV show for a couple seasons Joel
Kinnaman is coming back from the first
film is Rick Flagg Margot Robbie is
coming back as Harley Quinn and I'll
explain the timeline a little bit
because she's also going to be in
birds-of-prey
early next year too then Amanda Waller
from the last film is coming back so
that's already a lot of characters but
you can kind of tell what's going on
most of you have probably figured it out
why you have a bunch of actors here most
of whom are comedians like Pete Davison
Flula Borg what are they doing on a
Suicide Squad team early prediction is
probably because this is just the early
version of the team at the beginning of
the movie that they kill off right away
in a big action scene then Amanda Waller
goes and puts a more competent version
of the team together but then I know
you're asking which characters are gonna
be on that second version of the team
and will any of these ones from the
early ridiculous team survive so early
prediction for the second version of the
team because we don't see a lot of
characters in here second version is
rick flagg
coming back Idris Elba's vigilante
because he seems like he'd be way more
badass Idris Elba just isn't known for
playing incompetent characters and a lot
of these people seem like they're gonna
wind up being pretty incompetent in the
beginning of the film
maybe Ty Cobb ITD's mystery character
Harley Quinn obviously gonna be on the
second version of the team she'll
survive
maybe Captain Boomerang survives maybe
they'll kill him off because he was
pretty ridiculous in the first film but
maybe James Gunn will try to redeem him
somehow through the script boomerangs a
jewel thief
so de scaizi character and not really
necessarily lockable and David really
wanted me to find my inner [ __ ]
pretty much these words john cena's
peacemaker will probably be on that
second version of the team just because
john cena typically plays really badass
characters just because king shark is
such an awesome character he'll probably
be on that second version of the team
Peter Capaldi might not be a member of
The Suicide Squad he might just be
playing another character that works for
Amanda Waller then maybe the ratcatcher
character just because they try to
balance it in terms of number of women
number of men on the team they haven't
said who the villains going to be but
this will take place after the events of
the first Suicide Squad movie after the
events of Justice League and after the
events of the birds of prey movie so
really easy way to explain why Margot
Robbie's Harley Quinn isn't here for
this early version of the team because
why wouldn't they just put her back on a
version of the Suicide Squad is because
she's often Gotham doing whatever she's
doing during birds of prey then probably
gets thrown back in prison and given
another opportunity by Amanda Waller
what they'll probably do in terms of
referencing the events of the first film
is that Amanda Waller will have a couple
lines of dialogue poking fun at how
terrible the original version of the
team was and how they barely survived by
the skin of their teeth accomplishing
their goal of getting rid of the
enchantress well they'll probably do
four characters like Will Smith's
Deadshot who aren't coming back as
they'll just say they're off with their
daughter or they're off doing some other
mission but I think the story concept
for introducing this early incompetent
version of the team then killing them
off right away is brilliant there's a
rumor right now that it's going to be
rated R so it makes sense if you're
gonna have a big gory action scene where
you kill all your characters off in the
first 15 minutes that it would be a
rated R film for a little while there
were rumors that they were gonna try and
use Black Adam as one of the villains
but then that went away in the Black
Adam movie turned into something
different so there is a bunch of big DC
movie stuff happening right now the
Joker movie just blew up I've already
done a bunch of videos about that and
then on the TV shows they have crisis on
Infinite Earths coming up which is
basically their big version of Avengers
infinity war and Avengers end game with
all the TV characters so if you have any
big questions about Suicide Squad or any
of the other big DC movies that are
coming up or bonus videos you want to
request just let me know in the comments
everybody click here to watch Joaquin
Phoenix talk about doing a joker movie
sequel and click here for my Joker movie
end
video in Easter eggs thank you so much
for watching everybody put on a happy
face I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]